Вітаю, друзі!
Мене звати Марія Растворова.
Я вчитель географії Новопечерської школи.
Сьогодні
ми з вами продовжуємо вивчення географії
для 10 класу.
Сьогодні ми з вами дізнаємося,
які є основні галузі виробництва
та господарства Австралійського Cоюзу,
яке їх географічне розташування
та більше дізнаємося
про зовнішньоекономічні
зв'язки Австралійського Cоюзу.
На початку нашого уроку давайте
пригадаємо матеріали попередньої теми.
Увага на екран!
Згадали?
Молодці, рухаємося далі.
Також одразу надам відповіді
на питання тестів,
які були наприкінці минулого уроку.
Увага на екран!
Співпало?
Супер. Ідемо далі.
І для початку згадаємо –
яким чином відбувалося господарське
освоєння Австралійського континенту?
Нагадаю, що наприкінці 18 ст.
розпочалася британська колонізація,
що значно визначила подальший
розвиток Австралійського континенту.
Малюнок з тим, як британці
прибувають на Австралійський континент
ви можете побачити на слайді.
Згодом,
у зв'язку з великими вільними
площами в Австралії,
що мали пасовищну рослинність,
на материку швидкими
темпами розвивається вівчарство.
І дотепер,
забігаючи наперед, скажу –
Австралія є
країною-лідером за
кількістю поголів'я овець.
На цьому малюнку ви можете побачити,
як виглядала ферма
в 18-19 ст.
з вирощування овець.
Таким чином, в умовах
британської колонізації,
протягом тривалого періоду часу,
господарство Австралії розвивалося
як аграрно-сировинне.
На сьогоднішній день все значно змінилося
і Австралія є високорозвиненою
економічною країною
з ринковою економікою та
високими стандартами життя.
Дізнаємося більше
про секторальну структуру
економіки Австралійського Союзу.
Спочатку пригадаємо,
що означає поняття
секторальна структура економіки
та які галузі включає
кожен з секторів економіки.
Увага на екран!
Згадали, що таке секторальна
структура економіки.
Супер! Ідемо далі.
Пропоную вам подивитися на слайд
та проаналізувати,
які сектори економіки
переважають в господарстві Австралії.
Дивлячись на діаграму, бачимо,
що найбільша частина
належить сфері послуг,
яка займає 71%.
25% належить промисловості
і лише 4% – це надходження
від сільського господарства.
Таким чином, можна зрозуміти,
що Австралійський Союз характеризується
постіндустріальним етапом розвитку.
Тепер пропоную розглянути
галузі та розміщення
кожного із секторів економіки,
починаючи із найбільш
розвинутого в Австралії
третинного сектору економіки.
Нагадаю, що третинний сектор економіки
включає в себе різноманітні види послуг.
І Австралія є однією
із країн-лідерів в світі
за наданням наукових послуг,
тому що їй вдалося вдало поєднати
свій досвід
видобутку корисних копалин
і сучасні IT-технології.
Увага на екран!
І ось на цьому слайді ви бачите
приклад такої карти,
де позначені заплановані родовища
і ті родовища, які вже освоюються.
Науковими центрами Австралії є Канберра,
Брісбен
та Сідней.
Також серед галузей третинного сектору
розвинутою в Австралії є фінансова сфера.
Чотири австралійські банки
входять до рейтингу 50
найбільш надійних банків світу.
Коли ми говоримо про
третинний сектор Австралії,
неможливо не згадати про туристичну сферу.
Туризм надзвичайно розвинутий в Австралії
в зв'язку з величезною кількістю
унікальних природних об'єктів
та історико-культурних об'єктів.
І зараз
ми побуваємо в деяких з них.
На першій фотографії
бачимо унікальний
природний об'єкт Австралії –
Великий Бар'єрний риф,
найдовше коралове пасмо в світі.
Загадкова скеля Улуру.
Острів Фрейзер, відомий
своїми піщаними пляжами.
Національний парк Какаду.
Серед історико-культурних об'єктів
можна згадати
місто Голд-Кост, яке є таким
собі австралійським Голлівудом.
Звичайно, це – оперний
театр в місті Сідней.
В Австралії достатньо розвинутий
туризм, пов'язаний з серфінгом.
Розвиток транспорту
є запорукою успішного розвитку країни.
В Австралії найбільш поширеним
є автомобільний транспорт.
Це зумовлено тим, що
Австралія має великі простори та відстані
і відповідно необхідно, щоб
вони були поєднані між собою.
Саме тому в Австралії кожна родина
має свій автомобіль.
І поширені також, так
звані, автомобільні поїзди –
це такі колони машин,
які доставляють вантажі
на дуже далекі відстані.
Розвинутим також в Австралії
є залізничний транспорт.
Залізничний транспорт
відіграє дуже важливу роль
в гірничо-видобувній промисловості,
а також приміські залізничні
сполучення є біля великих міст,
зокрема Мельбурну,
Сіднею, Канберри та інших.
Морський транспорт
є надзвичайно важливим для Австралії,
бо Австралія веде
активну зовнішню торгівлю,
зокрема з країнами Східної Азії.
Найбільшими портами є міста
Брісбен, Кернс, Мельбурн і Сідней.
Говорячи про Австралію, неможливо
не згадати про повітряний транспорт.
В Австралії розташовано
приблизно 300 аеропортів
і найбільшими з них є
аеропорти в містах
Аделаїда, Сідней, Мельбурн.
Первинний сектор
економіки є надзвичайно важливим
для господарства Австралії.
І для того, щоб ми в це повірили,
наведу деякі цифри.
Увага на екран!
Найбільшого розвитку набули
такі галузі видобувної промисловості.
Вчитель перераховує галузі видобувної
промисловості, які ви бачите на дошці.
Пропоную більше дізнатися
про вугільну промисловість Австралії.
Вугілля видобувають в
кожному штаті Австралії,
але найбільше видобувають
його в таких штатах як
Квінсленд, Новий Південний
Уельс та штаті Вікторія.
Переважно
Австралія експортує
вугілля до країн Східної Азії.
І важливо зазначити,
що 85% електроенергії
Австралійського Союзу
виробляється на теплових електростанціях,
паливом для яких є кам'яне вугілля.
На слайді
ми можемо бачити як виглядає
одна із вугільних шахт Австралії.
Цікаво те, що Австралійський Союз
на високому рівні
забезпечений урановими рудами.
Нагадаю, що уран є паливом
для ядерних реакторів
і основною сировиною для
атомної електроенергетики.
Втім, на території
Австралії немає жодної АЕС,
а свій уран вона експортує до інших країн.
Таке рішення уряду та
австралійського народу
було зумовлено
страшними наслідками
трагедії на Чорнобильській АЕС
у 1986 році,
тому Австралія вирішила відмовитися
від спорудження АЕС на своїй території.
Рухаємося далі
та дізнаємося більше
про такі галузі первинного сектору
як рослинництво та тваринництво.
Бачимо цих милих тварин на слайді.
Австралія є світовим
лідером з поголів'я овець.
Також Австралія є лідером
в світі з настригу вовни.
Одна третина всього
поголів'я овець Австралії
зосереджена в штаті Новий Південний Уельс.
І основною продукцією
галузі вівчарства Австралії
є виробництво дуже дорогої та
якісної вовни мериносів (мerino),
яка широко використовується
для вовняної промисловості.
Останнім часом розвивається
м'ясна галузь вівчарства.
Також в Австралії, окрім
вівчарства на півночі,
розвинуте розведення
великої рогатої худоби
і також розвивається свинарство.
Коли ми говоримо про
рослинництво в Австралії,
важко зупинитися на чомусь одному.
Адже в Австралії вирощується
велике різноманіття
та великі обсяги
сільськогосподарських культур.
Сюди належать такі культури як: зернові,
олійні,
зернобобові, які використовуються
як продукти харчування,
так і як кормова база,
також вирощують ячмінь,
сорго,
бавовник вирощують на тих ділянках,
які спеціально зрошуються.
Також вирощують рапс,
овес,
люпин,
тропічні фрукти, зокрема
– апельсини та інші,
горіхи та овочі,
картоплю.
Цукрову тростину культивують на
півночі Австралійського континенту.
Надзвичайно важливою
галуззю економіки Австралії
є рибальство та аквакультура.
Зокрема рибальство – Австралія
виловлює і розводить
надзвичайно коштовну рибу тунця,
також існує ряд акваферм
з вирощування водоростей та
рибних і молюскових культур.
І також в Австралії
існують спеціальні ферми,
де вирощують справжні перлини.
Починаємо розглядати вторинний
сектор економіки Австралії.
Багата мінеральна база Австралії
та сприятливі агрокліматичні умови
зумовлюють достатню кількість
сировини для вторинного сектору.
Таким чином,
чорна і кольорова металургія Австралії
базується на власній сировині.
Основною продукцією металургійного
комплексу Австралійського Союзу
є: чавун,
сталь, прокат,
алюміній
та інші кольорові метали.
Основною продукцією
машинобудування Австралійського союзу
є: обладнання,
судна, катамарани,
позашляховики
та вантажні автомобілі.
Найбільшими центрами
машинобудування Австралії
є такі міста як Брісбен та Мельбурн.
Хімічна галузь в основному базується
та використовує продукти нафтопереробки
і основною її продукцією є
фарби, хімікати, шини та інше.
Розповідаючи про вторинний
сектор економіки Австралії,
неможливо не згадати про
харчову промисловість країни,
яка також, в основному,
базується на власній сировині
і є надзвичайно різноманітною.
Також не можна не згадати про легку
промисловість Австралії, яка відома
своїми виробами із
вовни мериносів (мerino).
В зв'язку з різною вартістю
праці в різних регіонах світу,
переважно австралійська
продукція виготовляється в Китаї.
Переходимо до
зовнішньоекономічних зв'язків Австралії.
Будь ласка, давайте
звернемо увагу на карту.
На цій карті,
що має назву “Міжнародні економічні
(зовнішньоекономічні) зв’язки”
ми можемо з вами бачити –
яка продукція є основною
для експорту та імпорту
для кожної країни світу.
Будь ласка,
уважно роздивіться цю карту
та на основі легенди
визначте,
які є основні статті
експорту та імпорту Австралії.
Це буде одне з ваших домашніх завдань.
Називаючи основні факти
про експорт та імпорт Австралії,
зазначу, що основними
торгівельними партнерами Австралії
є країни Східної Азії.
Більшу частину своєї
мінеральної сировини Австралія
експортує саме до країн Східної Азії.
Втім, сама Австралія імпортує 85% нафти.
Таким чином, сьогодні на уроці
ми з вами дізналися багато нового
про господарство та його секторальну
структуру в Австралійському Союзі.
Сподіваюся, ви запам'ятали
які галузі первинного,
вторинного і третинного сектору
є провідними в Австралії.
Питання для самоперевірки!
Питання та варіанти відповідей
на них ви бачите на екрані.
Правильні варіанти відповідей я
вам скажу на наступному уроці.
І переходимо з вами
до домашнього завдання.
Домашнє завдання ви бачите на екрані.
Подивившись запропонований
фільм, ви дізнаєтесь багато нового
про те, як відбувалось
господарське освоєння Австралії
та чому ця країна є такою саме зараз.
Дякую за увагу!
Ми з вами зустрінемося
на наступному уроці!